no and welcome to this video no no I've
got black I just okay I don't know what
for something I've got white again okay
it's black actually so playing something
else just happening some variety
yeah let's go see five and see yeah we
can actually transpose into Amarok see
with you for anyway okay that's not so
critical in comparison let's see what he
does here 92 is most frequently played
and then yeah here black has a mmm a
decent choice between lines you can take
on c3 which is objectively speaking
probably best but I don't I'm I'm always
a little bit skeptical about those
things
taking on on c3 the structure is
excellent but it's especially in blitz
it's sometimes tough to handle that is
aged 5h form actually decent option
Pepsi Pepsi okay never play this always
conveniently displayed here don't have
any prior games against this player
yeah the quick h5h force or h4 h5 with
white these have really been become very
popular in many openings and
understandably so it's quite often a
good way to get a fight going and you're
not risking all that much in most in
many cases most cases structurally
speaking you don't risk anything like
him I was very surprised that he
canceled after h4 man shows pretty good
nerves
it's not like I'm checkmating him
quickly but he
at least I have very easy plans very
easy plans
okay so Bishop h3 probably wants to
retreat okay
okay as I'm still playing at
hmm yeah how to get this really get this
rolling I wonder if I should take on Eve
on c3 now and really wonder because I'm
not entirely certain what this Bishop is
doing if I play Knight f6 okay I'm
playing this now for the head I wonder
if I should castle long in this position
it just looks so so weird
that makes a lot of sense
let's see what he's doing there 935 on I
don't I don't need to castle and he
terms so he just takes it okay hmm I
thought that helped me but again not
like immensely but but it bid okay so
what's going on here
racially brush crust I'm really close to
some funny things here hmm
and I can some long I'm threatening root
xh1
I think come on let's do it Ruka h1 king
h1 Bishop e3 check takes Queen f3 King
fg1 woogie Jaden's maid yeah am I not
just checkmating here I mean I think I
do
come on if it doesn't work it just uh
it's just a couple of rating points okay
I can I can play rook h8 first just that
help in any way not certain at the end
yes Knight b6 check he's got one check
and then I go King d8 and that's it it's
made it's just made what can you do and
still no nope remove so hey I was mainly
checking if King lukkage it first as any
better
he's got Knight takes is seven but I
still have a king d7 and no checks I'm
working I'm not sure what he is thinking
about
kingi one helping in some way I don't
think it is he has
oh yes c-5a dandiya to have Queen age
form
may its rate was just so late he doesn't
have c5 king the ages all of check them
he's in the age from is dangerous
so with them let's look at this with
long castling I thought I'm threatening
exactly what happened in the game and he
didn't react to it I think we should be
three it wins yeah yeah which one is
made in eleven made in eleven no it's
not to meet in nine okay sir all it
takes and probably rook age eight will
win as well iam check because I have
this move which is I saw that this is
funny
yeah this is made of course and King
takes doesn't help at night you five
check I mean okay the Queen but it's
made it's also made yeah this is
checkmate
I didn't 96 made and if you go yeah it's
it's made here yeah he says rematch yeah
this is one issue here because I I don't
mind giving a rematch but per say but
you cannot analyze them now you need you
need some some and I need some nail is
the same okay so this is what happened
Bishop f3 it takes it you got this and
that's the game basically it just Bishop
h6 okay and then it's over on h1 yeah so
Bishop e3 um yeah I kind of has
suspected that long castles is not the
best move but you if you see a trap like
that somehow or a threat that is not
super obvious it's very tempting to do
Queen f5 as a strong move
according to the comp yeah this is a
very strong threat
you cannot afford probably to grab grab
the rope him it's too much yeah yeah you
cannot save it like this is winning
quite convincingly yes this is a mate
yeah so Gaza's it's tempting to do it's
tempting to do nice and I I think that
he probably should not cancel on one
react to age five immediately I think
it's probably best to just play h4 and
stop this all together okay
thanks for watching